now you're me you may remember a
discussion of the birthday paradox which
says that if you have a group of 27
random people the probability is almost
two-thirds that some two of them are
gonna have a matching birthday even
though there are 365 birthdays in the
year and you might sloppily think that
with 27 people there'd only be a 27 out
of 365 or something a chance like that
it's actually 2/3 and by the time you
get to a class of a hundred and ten
which is what we'll be we have data for
and we're going to be looking at it
turns out that the odds are almost
three-quarters of a million to one that
you'll have a couple of people with
matching birthdays so let's look at the
matching birthday problem a little bit
more today and the reason we're looking
at it is because it's it's a lovely
example where there really is pairwise
independence and not mutual independence
so it's reinforcing the key idea behind
the additive 'ti of variance and the
pairwise independence sampling theorem
we're not going to use the sampling
theorem here but just pairwise
independence but it's worth looking at
now before I go further let me mention
that this the birthday problem is just
what we're doing for fun but in fact it
has some real applications in in more
than one area but the most famous one is
the so called birthday attack on a
cryptosystem which involves being able
to search for matching pairs of keys
with a relatively small sample and
you're very likely to find at least some
two that match so with that motivation
claimed but not examine let's just go
back to thinking about birthdays
okay so let's suppose that I have some
group of n people and there are D days
in the year just to keep the parameters
abstract and not get too stuck on the
numbers keeping the parameters makes it
actually a little bit clearer to reason
about
so we're implicitly assuming here that
each person is kind of a random variable
or a random choice of a birthday so each
of each of these people are really
random variables that return the value
of a birthday
and it's matter of fact we're going to
assume that all the birthdays are
equally likely real birthdays aren't
there they tend to be of January tends
to be a popular month November tends to
be a more popular month than other times
but let's ignore that because if the
applications in crypto things really are
uniform and it makes our analysis
possible it's still plausible but easy
if we assume that birthdays are equally
likely ok pay is the number of pairs of
birthdays that match in this population
of n people okay let's get a grip on P
by thinking of it as a sum of indicator
variables so let's let m IJ be the
indicator variable that the ICJ's people
among the N have a matching birthday
well the number of matching birthdays is
then simply the sum over all the
possible pairs of people of whether or
not they have a matching birthday it's
the sum of these indicator variables m
IJ and the number of these indicator
variables is of course all the ways of
choosing to an event people so in short
if I look at the expectation of m IJ
let's think about that for a minute
we're assuming that all the birthdays
are equally likely and so I'm asking
whether the ice and the J people have
the same birthday well whatever the ice
person's birthday turns out to be let's
say it's November 5th
the J person who has a uniform
probability of equaling any birthday
still has a uniform probability one
chance in D of equaling November 5th
which happens to be my birthday okay so
in short the expected the probability
that any two people have a matching
birthday is one chance in D and that
means that the expectation of the
indicator variable for that event m IJ
is 1 over D and that tells us by
linearity of expectation that the
expected number of pairs is simply the
number of those pairs times the expected
number prepare and choose 2 times 1 over
D well as I said we have data for one
hundred and ten students so the expected
number of pairs in a collection of a
student body of a hundred and ten is a
hundred and ten choose two times one
over 365 or about 16.4 pairs is the
expected number of pairs of matching
birthdays okay now that's an expected
value how likely is it to be if I take a
selection of 110 students and I count
how many pairs of birthdays are there do
I really expect to get close to 16.4 or
not well what we're asking for is the
probability that P is near its mean that
the distance between P and 16.4 is
greater than K I hope that as K gets
bigger this probability is small and so
I'm really quite likely to have close to
16.4 birthdays in the my sample of a
hundred and ten
but this probability is one that's a
mess to calculate but we can get a grip
on it because the variance of P is easy
to calculate and that will allow us to
apply the chebyshev bound and gets some
kind of an estimate on the likelihood
that P is near its expectation so that
the key observation that we need is that
the indicator variables are pairwise
independent so let's think about the
indicator variable for the event that
the iPhone that Jeff people have the
same birthday let's call them Albert and
Rho so Albert's the ice person drew is
the jave person and I'm interested in
the event that Albert and drew have the
same birthday and let's compare that to
another pair of people and whether or
not they have the same birthday so let's
first of all think about Dave and Mike
whether David Mike have the same
birthday and I want to know are these
two events independent well remember we
are assuming that Albert's birthday is
independent of Drew's birthday is
independent of David's independence Mike
each of the people is supposedly chosen
independently and their birthdays are
independently or independent so it's
obvious that these two pairs that don't
overlap I'll have nothing to do with
each other and we don't have to worry
about them you could prove that formally
but it's it is obvious because each of
the individual /
days are independent now what's more
interesting is the case when I asked
whether or not
Rob Albert and drew having the same
birthday as independent of Albert and
Mike having the same birthday and that
one is not so obvious here's a way to
think about what could go wrong
suppose that in fact the birthdays
warrant uniform suppose that some
birthday was more common than others
okay that makes it more likely that if
Albert and drew have the same birthday
it slants things so that they're more
likely to have this very common birthday
than they would have been otherwise and
now once I know that they match and
therefore are more likely to have the
common birthday than they would have
without any information I know that
Albert is more likely to have this this
common birthday than otherwise and that
means that Mike is even more likely to
match Albert because Albert's got the
common birthday then Mike was to match
Albert without any further information
about what Albert's likely birthday was
you can think about that and it can be
worked out numerically easily enough so
a uniformity is going to be a crucial
factor here in order to conclude that
Albert and drew and Albert and Mike are
independent are mutually independent
events but let's go back and think about
it all we really need is that Mike is
uniform in order to conclude that these
two events are independent because we
know that Mike and drew an Albert are
separately are independent of each other
their birthdays are chosen independently
so that intuitively means that the
probability that mike has any given
birthday doesn't really matter what's
going on with Albert intro because Mike
is independent of Albert Andrew and if
we know that Mike's probability of
having a birthday is uniform then
whatever the birthday that Albert has
whether he matches true or not mike has
a one chance in the of hitting the same
birthday as whatever Albert wound up
having and that means that the
probability that Mike matches Albert is
the same one over d than it would have
Ben if we had no further information
this is an argument that in fact is made
rigorous innocent class problems and a
problem set but let's just take it as
plausible enough based on this hand
waving argument that I articulated that
these two events are independent
pairwise and so the corresponding
indicator events indicator variables M
Albert Drew and M Albert Mike are pair Y
are independent of each other yeah so
that's what we've argued but notice that
these events of pairwise matching is
certainly not three-way independent
because after all if I know that Albert
and drew have the same birthday and that
Albert and Mike have the same birthday I
absolutely know with certainty that Drew
and Mike have the same birthday so this
is a very nice basic example where you
have pairwise independence but not
three-way independence assuming that all
of these random variables Albert Drew
and Mike and the are uniform in what
birthday they have okay so let's go back
to counting birthdays the variance of an
indicator is PQ so in this case P is 1
over 365 and Q is 1 minus 1 over 365 and
because of pairwise independence the
variance of P which is the sum of the
mij is the variance of the number of
birthday pairs is the sum of those
variances it's a hundred and ten choose
two times the variance of the m IJ turns
out to be about sixteen point three
seven which means that the standard
deviation Sigma is less than four now I
can apply chebyshev because by the
chebyshev bound the probability that a
16.4 is within a two sigma is further
away than two sigma is only one chance
in four which means the probability that
it's within two sigma that the actual
number of measured pairs is within two
sigma of the expected number sixteen
point four is greater than 1 minus 1/4
or three quarters
there's a 3/4 chance that the number of
pairs that we find is within 2 Sigma of
the expected number 16.4 Sigma was about
4 so this is 8 which means that we're
expecting with 3/4 probability somewhere
between 8.4 meaning nine and 24.4
meaning 25 pairs so 75% of the time in a
class of 110 we're gonna find between 9
and 25 pairs of birthdays did that
actually happen well it did in our class
of 110 for whom we had data we actually
found 21 pairs of matching birthdays
literally we found 12 pairs in 3 triples
but each triple counts as three matching
pairs and there they are the Blues are
triples and you can see whether your
birthday is among those and knowing that
you have a classmate or two that have
the same birthday that you do so there
were 15 different birthdays but they
count as 21 pairs because it's 12 single
pairs and three triplets each of which
counts for 3 pairs